[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour un
nouveau débat à l'occasion du second
tour des municipales débat à suivre
aussi sur a2 sensation sur 98 points 4
aujourd'hui vous allez entendre les
trois candidats qui prétendent à la
mairie de guyancourt et ils sont avec
nous en ligne pour des raisons
sanitaires nous faisons ça en visio et
grégory pape bonsoir vous êtes la tête
de liste de nouvel élan à guyancourt bon
sens soit un feu baril à tête de liste
ensemble agissons pour guyancourt soir
et françois marton bonsoir vous êtes le
maire sortant et le représentant de la
liste guyancourt pour tous 2020 des
saisons ensemble à guyancourt
avant de vous donner la parole messieurs
je vous propose de nous intéresser
quelques minutes aux enjeux de la
commune guyancourt ville de 29 mille
habitants et membres de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour le second
tour des élections municipales trois
listes sont en lice françois morton le
maire sortant est arrivé en tête avec 42
% des voix il est suivi de rodolphe
barry candidats ensemble agissons pour
guyancourt se maintient aussi grégory
pas candidat et les oem et tête de liste
nouvel élan à guyancourt
à noter qu'un quatrième candidat s'était
présenté en mars dernier l'écologiste
olivier paréja choisi de rallier la
liste de françois morton avec sept
autres colistiers principal enjeu à
guyancourt l'ancienne friche thales et
son aménagement cette zone implanté
entre l'avenue léon blum et sept de
leurs apps devrait accueillir d'ici 2030
plus de 1300 logements des commerces des
activités économiques des espaces verts
et des services publics sur plus de 22
hectares le site qui sera baptisé le
quartier des savoirs va accueillir
également la future station de métro
saint quentin est du grand paris express
un super métro reliant orly à versailles
en 30 minutes
avec ce nouveau quartier le nombre de
guyancourt toit devrait passer de 29
mille à 32000 les logements justement
seront d'un deuxième enjeu à guyancourt
la ville compte actuellement près de 48
% des logements sociaux
c'est 18% de plus que la moyenne des
communes voisines est la ville a entamé
depuis quelques années une
reconfiguration de ses quartiers
notamment des transformations dans le
quartier du pont du routard depuis 2006
l'un des plus vieux quartiers de la
ville créée en 1974
dernier point les entreprises la ville
compte à ce jour 2536 firme sur son
territoire presque 1000 de plus qu'en
parmi elles des grandes entreprises
comme sodexo le groupe à ce mode est
spécialisé dans les jeux de société ou
encore le technocentre renault qui
emploie près de 9500 personnes
la ville doit elle accueillir plus
d'entreprises ces enjeux ont été
développées lors du premier débat
diffusé sur notre antenne en février
dernier un débat que vous pouvez
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile
d'autres thèmes vont être abordés
aujourd'hui des thèmes choisis à
l'avance comme la sécurité ou encore
l'éducation
le temps de parole des candidats sera
bien évidemment chronométrés je ferais
régulièrement le point sur leur durée
pour fixer le premier tour de prise de
parole la rédaction a choisi de se
conformer à l'ordre établi par la
préfecture des yvelines lors de dépôt de
listes et on débute avec une première
question et c'est vous grégory patat
votre liste nouvel élan à guyancourt est
enregistrée lrm vous arrivait en
troisième position le 15 mars dernier
avec 18 % des suffrages comment vous
abordez ce second tour bonsoir merci à
vous déjà pour l'organisation de ce de
ce débat qui va nous permettre de de
présenter nos idées à l'ensemble des
encours toi moi je voulais vraiment
commencé par remercier les électeurs qui
m'ont accordé leur confiance au premier
tour car je comprends que il ya une
forte abstention
du fait des conditions sanitaires et
d'ailleurs moi dès le lendemain du
premier tour
j'ai pris conscience de la gravité de la
crise sanitaire
rappelez-vous le président de la
république parler de l'état de guerre et
je vous confirme qu'en tant que
professionnel de santé
nous étions vraiment en guerre en guerre
contre le coroner virus soit moi j'ai vu
des choses horribles que je ne pensais
vraiment pas jamais vit vraiment jamais
bien et le projet je voulais vraiment
aussi profiter de mes le temps d'antenne
ce soir pour adresser une pensée à tous
les lions courtois qui ont été touchés
pendant cette période moi je savais que
que cette campagne du deuxième tour
serait pas normal serait biaisée et que
nous aurions très peu d espace pour
promouvoir nos idées donc pour moi
l'heure était à l'union sacrée
j'ai proposé aux trois autres candidats
de nous unir et d'unir nos forces entre
candidats plutôt que nous diviser et
dépenser votre énergie au combat et j'ai
proposé pour cela que pendant le pendant
la période de confinement une liste
inédite d'unions locales dont la
composition aurait respecté la
proportionnelle des résultats du 1er
tour afin de pouvoir gérer la ville
ensemble dans l'intérêt général ce qui
nous aurait permis de ne prendre aucun
risque
pendant cette période de campagne du
deuxième tour
ainsi je voulais donner un bel exemple
de démocratie locale qui tenait compte
de l'avis de tous les habitants et je
voulais prouver ou durand courtois qu'on
était capables de travailler ensemble en
mettant nos ego de côté
malheureusement les trois autres
candidats ont refusé donc nous repartons
en concurrence pour ce deuxième tour
mais pour moi cet épisode de crise
sanitaire n'a fait que renforcer mes
préoccupations pour lui en cours santé
sécurité solide avec son équipe
on développe grâce à un peu plus dans le
débat qui va sur ce que vous êtes déjà
très en avance sur le temps monsieur pas
ben je vais maintenant donner la parole
à rodolphe varie vous êtes le candidat
de la liste ensemble agissons pour
guyancourt une liste classé divers
centres lors du premier tour vous
obtenez 22 70 % même question quand vous
comment vous abordez ce second tour
écoutez bonsoir déjà tout le monde m'a
coûté jeu la mort de la vente de manière
sereine même si la tâche d'être
compliqué gilles a marché ou éternité
mais avait pas pour moi impossible
aggravé donc on l'attend dimanche
prochain pour savoir ce que les
électeurs vont dessiner je vois juste
avec moi juste je suis tête de liste
d'une liste qui s'appellera pg ensemble
agissons pour lui en cours qui est une
liste indépendante d'intérêt local
d'intérêt communal
on a travaillé depuis deux ans sur ce
projet qui va projet les trente sept
colistiers qui sont tous là aujourd'hui
sur un projet local pour les bus en
courtois avec un seul objectif qui était
pas de critiquer forcément ce qui a été
fait par la municipalité actuelle du
restic est au pouvoir depuis trente six
ans mais c'était plutôt comme objectif
de se dire on
améliorant ce que l'on peut améliorer
créons ce que l'on peut créer puis ce
qui est bien et qui marche le gabon
continueront le garder alors vive voix
la france importe on va terminer avec
vous ce premier tour de parole vous êtes
le maire sortant élu en 2014 sur la
liste menée par françois de ligne et
vous êtes élu à la tête de la commune en
mai 2010 9 après les démissions
successives de françois denis et marie
christine de tarnac
vous êtes tête de liste guyancourt pour
tous 2020 décidons ensemble à guyancourt
c'est issu de la fusion avec une autre
liste du premier tour celle emmenée par
olivier paréja une liste enregistré
comme divers gauche et soutenu par le
parti socialiste au premier tour arrive
en tête avec 42 % des voix même question
pour vous comment vous abordez ce second
tour alors avant de répondre à votre
question je voudrais également avoir une
pensée d'un mois toutes les vérités
parce que nous avons été tellement
douloureux
j'aurais également une pensée pour tous
les soignants les commerçants les
fonctionnaires voilà une grande pensée
pour les fonctionnaires qu'ils soient
des fonctionnaires d'état ou des
fonctionnaires hospitaliers ou
territoriaux c'est évidemment grâce à
eux que de nos services publics a pu
tenir et continuer à fonctionner en ce
qui concerne votre question alors la
fusion des deux listes dont du encore
pour tous 2020 et décidons ensemble à
guyancourt elle a été assez simple parce
que effectivement nous avions un socle
commun de valeurs évidente et donc on a
pu se rejoindre très facilement au
moment où nous avons repris un certain
nombre de discussions au moment du
décompte final
voilà et donc effectivement nous sommes
très fiers de ce rassemblement c'est un
rassemblement qui très probablement
était attendue par les gluons courtois
et nous sommes parfaitement heureux
voilà pour une première prise de parole
ont fait un petit tour des chronos à
grégory pas vous avez pris beaucoup
d'avancé avait déjà à deux minutes de
temps françois morton et rodolphe le
baril vous êtes tous les deux en dessous
de la minute ne vous est plus ou moins à
égalité
je propose qu'on débute avec la première
thématique c'est celle de l'éducation
alors sur guyancourt il y à 25 écoles
publiques ce sont treize écoles
maternelles 12 établissements
élémentaires chaque école est notamment
équipé d'un chariot numérique
avec un vidéoprojecteur interactif et sa
tablette numérique
c'est un plan numérique que rodolphe
baril vous souhaitez continuer pour
accroître la réussite scolaire oui bon
oui effectivement c'est un sujet c'est
un sujet important
puis en cours est en retard soit le
déploiement de tout ce qui est numérique
via un plan triennal qui a été mis en
place entre la région saint quentin en
yvelines et puis et puis la commune
il est important que l'ensemble des
écoles souhaité équiper de l'ensemble
des outils numériques pour pouvoir
pourquoi travailler alors ça fait pas
tout évidemment c'est pas la priorité
puisque le numérique n'est n'est pas
l'unique moyen de faire de l'éducation a
eu droit les écoles en tout cas c'est un
moyen qui aujourd'hui il faut être dans
l'air du temps qu'il faut absolument
avoir dans les écoles françois morton
vous vous souhaitez notamment maintenir
l'ensemble des aides municipales à la
scolarité qui sont fourniture gratuite
livres pour les cp et continuer ce plan
numérique
sur le plan des numériques je vais me
permettre juste de préciser puisque vos
informations madame poké date et
probablement de l'année 2019 et depuis
le mois de décembre dernier
l'ensemble des classes des écoles
élémentaires sont toutes équipées de v
pays donc voilà je le précise parce que
ça c'était la situation au début d'année
2010 neuf donc bien évidemment nous
avons évolué avec le plan que mentionné
d'ailleurs monsieur barry ne concerne
pas la région mais le département et
donc nous avons pu effectivement avancer
sur ce plan numérique mais comme du jeu
non je ne rejoins également sur ce point
là c'était le numérique ne fait pas tout
et l'ensemble des aides à la scolarité
et d'un importante je parlerai
évidemment de tout ce qui est
périscolaire vous avez cité les et 25
écoles mais c'est aussi doux de loisirs
dans la ville dans tous les quartiers
toujours à proximité effectivement de
des habitants de la ville
et puis je pourrais évidemment citer
d'autres vous avez parlé des classes de
découverte que nous souhaitons maintenir
mais aussi un sujet fort et un sujet
phare j'ai envie de dire qui est la
pérennisation de la scolarisation des
enfants de moins de 3 ans et ce sera
bien évidemment un vrai sujet parce que
depuis notamment le fait que la
scolarité à cinq ans
maintenant obligatoire cette
scolarisation des enfants de moins de 3
ans elle est très souvent et ça était
encore le cas cette année avec des
contacts avec l'éducation nationale
remise en question donc ce sera un vrai
un vrai combat et on y tient et on
livrera un combat
grégory pack vous dans votre programme
parmi vos propositions on trouve
notamment mettre en place des études
dirigées dans le périscolaire et les
maisons de quartier ouais en fait
l'éducation une des principales raisons
mon engagement politique parce que quand
quand je vais chercher mes garçons à
l'école élémentaire une des principales
discussions qui revient à la sortie
d'école c'est vous est ce que vous allez
mettre vos enfants dans le privé l'année
prochaine ou dès le collège et je trouve
c'est pas normal
donc du coup moi je constate cette suite
des élèves durant courtois voilà je me
dis mais où est passé lui en cours pour
tous va donc c'est pour ça que me suis
dit vas-y va travailler là-dessus est en
fait en creuse ans et je me suis rendu
compte que c'était multifactorielle et
je trouve que à guyancourt
nous devrions plus valoriser la réussite
des élèves dans courtois notamment par
une soirée des réussites
il faudrait qu'on l'épreuve leur propose
des concours d'éloquence c'est-à-dire de
s'entraîner est ce qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment c'est super important
dans la vie il faut qu'on accompagne nos
jeunes dans la réussite mais c'est un
challenge et c'est un challenge qui
consiste à tirer vers le haut mais tout
en laissant à personne sur le bord de la
route
rodolphe varie vous avez un peu de
retard par rapport aux autres candidats
ce que vous souhaitez rebondir sur une
notion de votre programme
oui si on est toujours sur le sujet de
la de l'éducation il y avait trois axes
en fait nous on a travaillé
indépendamment du déploiement numérique
et le droit dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure il ya l'amélioration de la
gestion et de la flexibilité
l'amélioration de la qualité de la
communication aussi avec entre les
jantes les établissements scolaires et
puis là la municipalité
je vous donne juste un exemple qui m'a
été rapporté par les parents d'élèves
par des enseignants
voilà on parle de contre l'inscription à
différentes activités périscolaires
loulou scolaire
les se fait à partir de listes ou qu'ils
voulaient aujourd'hui il faut utiliser
tout ce qui est numérique pour améliorer
la flexibilité coupe à porto par
certains parents souhaitent alors plus
de flexibilité dans les autres les
inscriptions aux activités périscolaires
ça moyen de moyens de le développer par
exemple
la deuxième chose c'est la transition
numérique on en a parlé tout à l'heure
et puis une idée aussi de construire une
relation une relation attente il est
complémentaire avec entre les
enseignants les enseignants et la
municipalité ça c'est vraiment très très
important une fois nous on est pour le
service minimum tout en respectant
droite claque je sais que c'est quelque
chose qui est avec nous si on marque on
ne valide pas mais on nous en tout cas
on est pour l'instauration d'un service
minimum tout en respectant contre le
trop grave il ya aussi la valorisation
des associations pour les faire
travailler alors qu'elles soient
culturelles qu'elles soient sportives
qu'elles soient toutes les associations
qui puisse exister mais qui n'a
toutefois s'il associatif qui est assez
important et qu'on puisse arriver à les
faire travailler avec les établissements
scolaires notamment
il fait intervenir dans les hôtels dans
les établissements scolaires monsieur
pas vu pendant quelques instants mais
est ce que monsieur pourtant vous
souhaitez réagir à ce qui a été prononcé
[Musique]
par conséquent oui c'est monsieur
longtemps d'abord monsieur je vous donne
ma parole je sais après je pense que je
me suis déjà suffisamment exprimé sur le
sujet ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que l'éducation c'est un vrai projet
politique ça ne s'arrête pas aux écoles
ça concerne aussi la culture par exemple
et la culture qui n'a jamais été une
variable d'ajustement sur la ville de
biot pour et je tiens à souligner que
par exemple cette année pour la première
fois la ville de billancourt n'aura
aucun fonds concours au niveau de la
culture est la part de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est à dire que à guyancourt ça n'est
pas une variable d'ajustement salé au
niveau de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et notamment auprès
des amis de monsieur barry pas par là
même je voudrais aussi dire que
l'éducation c'est un partenariat avec
les enseignants et bien évidemment avec
les parents et il existe aussi des
dispositifs d'accompagnement à la
parentalité je pense notamment à l'école
des parents guyancourt il ya énormément
de succès monsieur pas vous souhaitiez
réagir
en quelques secondes ce que vous avez
encore un peu d' avance par rapport aux
autres candidats
non juste soit effectivement cours pour
souligner les propos de monsieur barry
sur le service minimum d'accueil
on en avait déjà parlé au premier au
premier débat sur sur votre plateau mais
je je comprends pas pourquoi la la
municipalité actuelle de ne souhaite pas
de mettre en place
entendons-nous bien je suis pour le
droit de grève ça ne pour moi ça ne va
vraiment pas un an de comptines droit de
grève mais on doit aider parents
d'élèves qui vivent un calvaire le jour
les jours de grève donc pour moi un
maire doit défendre d'abord défendre ses
habitants avant de défendre ses opinions
politiques
un petit tour sur les chronomètres
grégory pape pardon vous êtes à trois
minutes 27 francs sont pourtant vous le
suivez de près à trois minutes 15
rodolphe le baril un petit peu en retard
3 min 03 s que quelqu'un souhaite encore
s'exprimer sur le thème de l'éducation
oui moi je juste rebondir
justement hier sur la réflexion de
monsieur morton qui nous dit que ce sont
mes amis
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est travailler
en bonne intelligence avec une
communauté d'agglomération faudra que la
communauté d'agglomération aujourd'hui à
50% des compétences sur la commune
quelle que soit la gouvernance qu'il
peut y avoir un intérêt l'objectif pour
lui aux courses et travaille en bonne
intelligence avec la cogneuse du réseau
notamment c'est le troisième thème de ce
débat je lui propose de partir sur le
deuxième thème maintenant il s'agit de
la sécurité n'ont que quelques
informations sur la commune actuellement
il ya 22 caméras de vidéoprotection qui
sont déployés d'un point de vue humain
ce sont 19 agents municipaux 14
policiers 5-1 svp sur 15 ans hors
commune il ya notamment deux postes
d'éducateurs spécialisés qui ont été
créés et françois morton justement
vous souhaitez créer un service
d'éducation spécialisée vous pouvez nous
expliquer un petit peu oui c'est une
nécessité
et encore une fois c'est en lien avec un
désengagement d'un certain nombre de
collectivités au département des
yvelines puisque cette compétence de la
prévention spécialisée c'est une de ses
compétences et on voit bien que depuis
un certain nombre d'années maintenant
j'ai eu la chance d'occuper de ce
quartier bon avant d'être maire donc en
comptant 4 juin j'ai pu voir
effectivement claude cette présence et
celle que des défauts un maire
effectivement il a des valeurs il doit
s'engager il doit être convaincu des
fêtes et la ville de bécancour a décidé
effectivement de palier en créant un
service d'éducation stéphanie blais
grégory pape
vous souhaitez un plan d'investissement
de 500 mille euros
si jamais vous êtes maire weir et ses
105 0 c'est un sujet que je prendrai à
bras le corps parce que depuis depuis
deux ans nous avons commencé notre
campagne que nous sommes sur le terrain
nous rencontrons les gegants courtois
qui sont les xv a exaspéré fatigué de
plus être protégés efficacement
ils sont vraiment nombreux à craindre
pour leur sécurité et nous allons
effectuer un vrai travail de prévention
et de renforcement de la protection
pour cela il faudra lutter contre les
incivilités évidemment les dégradations
les nuisances nocturnes
on va commencer par renforcer les
effectifs et structurer les missions des
policiers municipaux sur la
vidéoprotection et d'huile en cours il
ya une vingtaine de caméras les caméras
évidemment ce n'est pas une solution
miracle mais au moins ça permettent
d'élucider les délits donc c'est un
premier pas quand même et moi je pense
qu'il faut systématiquement associés la
prévention à la répression
la prévention ça passe par l'ouverture
d'un pôle médiation dans lé quartier il
ya des dispositifs qui existent qui sont
les voisins vigilants ça c'est des
voisins qui met en place entre on
devrait on devrait le soutenir et de
mettre en place plus généralement et la
campagne de prévention ça passe aussi
par la communication regardez j'ai des
affiches comme ça je sais pas si vous
voyez bien je crois que j'avais vu ça à
nice c'est pour les crottes de chiens
voyez les crottes de chien finissent sur
mes mains sur mes mains maintenant vous
le savez alors ramassé les est ce que
vous voyez
et des campagnes de prévention comme ça
et puis en cours n'ont pour l'instant il
n'y a pas un manque d'audace
il faut donner un dynamisme et là dessus
et c'est ça que je reproche sur les
rodéos on est on est suivi tous les
soirs tous les soirs
en ce moment il ya une mission qui a été
confiée à natalia pouzy rêve qui est
député de saint germain en laye
profitons de cette proximité ne
serait-ce que géographique déjà pour
travailler main dans la main avec nos
députés et enfin si j'ai encore quelques
secondes je voulais dire que la sécurité
pour moi c'est aussi la sécurité
sanitaire
si nous sommes élus nous proposerons dès
cet été en partenariat avec les
professionnels de santé de la ville des
tests de dépistage au coronavirus au
bouillon pour toi qui le désirent et
donc moi je suis pharmacien et en cas de
deuxième vague vous inquiétez pas je
saurai vous trouver très rapidement les
équipements nécessaires les masse et les
gels hydro-alcooliques
je me rappelle mes priorités c'est que
votre temps vous aurez notamment
je revends peut-être la part elle un
tout petit peu après je vais faire
parler monsieur barry pour le moment ce
que vous avez beaucoup d'avancé sur les
autres candidats rudolph baril ont parlé
notamment du réseau de vidéoprotection
il y en a 22 actuellement vous vous
souhaitez monter jusqu'à 70 caméra vous
pouvez développer un petit peu tout à
fait mais jouer jusqu'aux lumières sur
le sujet des rangs puisque est morte on
va lancer une petite pique
je veux juste rappeler que je ne suis
pas élu on est déjà parlé on en
accueille la partie je vous propose
maintenant parés de la sécurité
notamment vos idées de sur votre
programme sur la sécurité
alors bon pour moi la sécurité et la
tranquillité publique et c'est un long
sujet c'est d'abord de la prévention il
faut savoir qu'historiquement après
explique mans mais récemment on va dire
la nasa est loin bien l'état s'est
désengagé des missions de police de
proximité de la police nationale alors
je sais que rien des accords entre moi
et monsieur morton entre monsieur martin
et moi pardon sur le sujet puisque moi
je pense que la police de proximité doit
être assurée par la police municipale
qui elle peut avoir un rôle beaucoup
plus importante de prévention que la
police nationale puisqu'il police
municipale allait vraiment ancrée et
quand on sait que l'état se désengage de
ce cas on n'a pas d'autre choix
aujourd'hui c'est pragmatique vous
regardez ce qui se passe dans les autres
communes
de saint quentin en yvelines la police
de proximité fait par les polices
municipales le la première priorité
c'est de travailler la prévention et
pour travailler la prévention il faut
avoir à la fois il brésil de principal
qu'ils soient en cohérence avec la
population avec le territoire dont on
avait pu en cours et puis également
renforcer toute la partie animateur et
éducateur spécialisé qui vont être en
relais avec la police municipale parce
qu'une police municipale qui est ancré
sur la commune elle connaît tout le
monde est plein de contacts peut
discuter elle peut échanger
elle finit par connaître tout le monde
une police nationale quant à l'intérieur
on ne les connaît pas et en règle
générale il ya de la défiance parce
qu'ils arrivent juste pour sanctionner
pas pour faire de la prévention
c'est comme ça qu'elle est perçue donc
voila mais les grandes longueurs du
projet de sur la sécurité et la
tranquillité publique voyez sur les
caméras de vidéoprotection et non de
vidéosurveillance devraient jeu se
rassurer ceux qui se rend compte que
c'est très encadré
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
encadré vous ne pouvez pas poser une
caméra le maire ne peut pas j'aurais eu
à dire jamais une caméra l'âge même
caméra ailleurs c'est dans quelque chose
qu'il faut déclarer en préfecture
donc ils nécessitent des autorisations
spécifiques avec un encadrement qui rend
très très rigoureux l'objectif c'est
d'en avoir effectivement à la fin du
mandat soit en dise sachant que plus
qu'à moi on ne le mange pas politique
budgétairement la région la semaine dans
la région et par département la région
finance l'installation des caméras de
vidéo conditions d'une partie aux
communes en font la demande à la banque
un plan de déploiement et qui ne vont
pas nier la région monsieur mortaud est
ce que vous souhaitez répondre on a
notamment parlé d'incivilités de manque
de signalétique
oui monsieur alors d'abord je voudrais
préciser quelque chose pour d'abord
jeu-concours pas où est le la différence
entre ce que dit monsieur barry est ce
que je dis je n'ai pas très bien compris
où était notre désaccord sur cette
affaire-là mais c'est pas grave on aura
l'occasion d'en sur les rodéos plus
aucun cas évoqués monsieur pape alors je
le rassure tout de suite puisqu'on
initiative l'ensemble des maires de
saint quentin en yvelines adressé un
courrier juste au moment du décompte
final
heures à monsieur castaner et à la
députée plaisir f pour que effectivement
nous puissions échanger pour donner les
moyens d'agir aux policiers parce
qu'effectivement je considère que c'est
la tâche de la police nationale encore
une fois le maire n'est pas commissaire
la mairie ça n'est pas la place beauvau
voilà et donc les missions de chacun
doivent être parfaitement définis en
termes des caméras vous l'avais dit au
début de mandat il y avait quinze
caméras sur la ville il y en a
actuellement 22 l'installation d'une
caméra je le rappelle quand même ses
10000 euros
voilà pour c'est l'ordre de grandeur en
termes d'installation et de
fonctionnement et à un moment donné pour
passer de 22 à soixante dix il faudra
aussi qu'on nous explique sur quel
budget au dépend de quoi on pourrait
techniquement les financements de ces
caméras maintenant au delà du nombre ce
qui est important c'est la pertinence
des implantations des caméras et c'est
ce que nous avons toujours fait en
partenariat avec la police nationale et
les habitants puisque toutes les
dernières caméras implantées ont été
fait en concertation avec les habitants
décident
voilà un petit point sur les temps de
parole rodolphe et barrez vous atteignez
quasiment les six minutes
grégory pas vous êtes aux alentours de 5
30 françois marteau en dessous des 5 30
mennour équilibre ben ça bien sûr tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous souhaitez en
faire un tout petit mot sur cette
séquence mal an c'est vraiment 30
secondes avant de passer au dernier
thème monsieur pape on juge n'avait pas
terminé sur la sécurité sanitaire parce
que je voulais juste te dire que moi
j'ai imposé à mon équipe sur le terrain
le port du masque et quand je vois les
autres listes qui n'emporte pas
systématiquement je trouve s'est passé
est complètement irresponsable ne fait
pas prendre de risques aux guyancourt
toi s'il vous plaît voilà c'est ce que
je voulais dire monsieur vous vous direz
h 06 30 secondes merci je voulais réagir
aux propos de monsieur morton sur le
financement
donc je reformule on avait même chiffre
sur le coût d'une caméra d'im est
presque pas pris la caméra que c'est
l'installation complète effectivement
entre 10 et 15 mai en général la région
finance une partie des caméras donc
l'idée c'est que la région finance une
dizaine d'îles une dizaine de caméras
par an c'est qu'on en arrive à les faire
financer par la région ou simplement par
contre je voulais poser une question à
monsieur bâtiments sont dans le vent son
nom dans son programme parle de 500
mille euros
sur six ans je voulais savoir comment il
allait utiliser ses six cent mille euros
sur six langues s'interpeller ça va
devenir compliqué il ya aussi un peu de
temps gérer monsieur papa parler du tout
à l'heure des 500000 euros pour égaliser
un petit peu le temps je peux donner
encore 30 secondes à monsieur morton
s'ils souhaitent s'exprimer sur la
sécurité autrement pas ce dernier thème
de ce débat je vais je vais les prendre
très rapidement
je ne comprends pas d'où vient ce
chiffre de 70 caméra sur la ville début
en cours et en quoi elles sont
nécessaires et la dernière chose c'est
que je sais et qui montre monsieur barry
et spécialiste des questions de sécurité
il a d'ailleurs été élu avec cette
délégation est fait comme moi mais je
rappelle quand même que le maire de sept
autres communes a comme moi
effectivement signé ce courrier
d'interpellation de l'intérieur pour les
incivilités notamment les rodéos ça veut
dire tout n'a pas été réglé
effectivement notamment comme un jeu
propose canclaux le thème de la sécurité
pour partir sur le dernier il s'agit de
la culture loisirs et sports vous êtes
plus ou moins à égalité monsieur barry
un tout petit peu d' avance mais on va
rattraper tout ça ennuie en cours au
terme de deux cultures possède deux
salles de spectacle la batterie consacre
essentiellement à la musique la ferme de
bel ébat c'est au théâtre du côté
sportif la ville accueille une trentaine
d'associations qui rassemble plus de
8000 est licencié un monde actuellement
encore touché par la crise puisque de
nombreuses activités n'ont pas encore
repris
grégory pape vous souhaitez notamment
l'ouverture des équipements sportifs et
culturels le soir et pendant les
vacances scolaires
ouais tout à fait ça c'est une réelle
demande
c'est vrai que on discute beaucoup être
la jeunesse si tu nous dis bah voilà le
soir la maison de quartier je parle à
cosma et le faire elles ferment à 18h
les gymnases sont se ferment à 20h je
crois quelque chose comme ça ils peuvent
ils aimeraient bien avoir des plus de
créneaux pour aller faire un foot pour
jouer pour faire un basket
nous ne souhaitons vraiment redonné vie
à guyancourt en travaillant sur des
nouveaux lieux conviviaux des lieux de
rencontre ait lieu pour strict des
grands événements nous allons créer un
festival culturel qui va fédérer la
jeunesse du en cours ont encore une fois
il faut lui faire confiance à notre
jeunesse faut pas l'abri mais nous
allons également créer une ludothèque
inter générationnelle
et puis au niveau spots au niveau
sportif nous avons créé un parcours de
santé développer encore plus baird
street work outs et déjà été fait à
guyancourt ça plaît beaucoup
donc ça c'est super nous avons également
pensé à aménager un club house pour que
quand vous dites il ya beaucoup
d'associations sportives dans la ville
mais qui aimerait bien avoir un peu plus
de convivialité après le match de foot
ou de tennis de pouvoir se retrouver
nous allons initier la fête du sport
pour réunir toutes les sections
sportives de guyancourt et comme vous
l'aviez dit aussi enfin je l'interpréter
comme ça nous sommes très très bien
dotée en équipements et guyancourt
mais je vais prendre juste un exemple je
trouve que le le pavillon waldec
rousseau c'est une superbe salle quel
est son taux d'occupation
on devrait s'en servir plus pour donner
accès aux grands événements et l'ouvrir
aux associations pour les grands
événements de la ville et nous avons un
projet phare également sic nous pensons
aux guyancourt toi qui ne partent pas en
vacances l'été qui ne peuvent pas partir
en vacances et nous allons organiser le
bruit en cours plage il sera un
événement en fait qui va envahir toutes
les animations que vous trouvez sur des
plages classique
j'ai d'ailleurs de lyon tête selon les
selon la taille haute il faudra et enfin
on en a on était réuni entre têtes de
listes afin notamment avec les deux
têtes de liste et l'association régal
hier soir pour parler de la ressourcerie
à guyancourt sais c'est un lieu qui me
tient vraiment à coeur et qui alliera la
solidarité le vivre ensemble et de
développement durable de france en
sortant je viens de parler de création
et notamment dans votre programme vous
proposer de créer un site d'escaladé sur
la commune ou encore une artothèque
absolument nous avons fait le choix de
pouvoir faire bénéficier l'ensemble des
habitants des oeuvres d'art que la ville
acquise durant ces années à chaque fois
qu'il pouvait y avoir une exposition
d'un artiste qu'il soit vu encore toi tu
est souvent le cas ou en tout cas d'
avec une portée régionale et donc nous
nous sommes en train de recenser et à
terme l'idée de pouvoir faire bénéficier
par prés ou petite location ne sait pas
encore mais en tout cas des habitants
qui pourrait en faire la demande
parce que nous avons une véritable et
très belle collection d'oeuvres d'art
que nous n'aurons tu
acquérir je vais revenir sur un certain
nombre de propos d'abord vous avez parlé
d'une trentaine d'associations vous
mentionniez bien évidemment que les
associations sportives
je rappelle que lui en course et 140
associations - au total donc une vraie
vie associative
monsieur papa je pense à prononcer un
mot malheureux parce que redonner vie à
guyancourt j'espère j'espère vraiment il
ne considère pas que lui en cours est
mort voilà parce que je trouve que cette
fronde de dénigrer systématiquement la
ville de huy en cours et on a pu
effectivement l'observer à maintes fois
durant cette campagne est assez
désagréable
la plupart des clients pour toi la très
grande majorité des gangs courtois
aiment leur ville et et c'est très bien
comme ça
voilà sur la vie associative nous allons
continuer effectivement à appuyer les
besoins à répondre aux besoins des
associations on parle y est demandeuse
d'un certain nombre de nouvelles
installations et work out mais il peut y
avoir évidemment le skate park qui est
actuellement en travaux
le maintien des salles gratuite je
rappelle que beaucoup de villes font
payer la location dvd des salles aux
associations alors il ne s'agit pas de
donner des subventions des associations
et ensuite leur reprendre au moment de
la location des salles ce n'est pas
effectivement notre politique à
guyancourt
voilà et puis surtout puisque nous
sommes dans une partie des sports
culture et loisirs
je dois dire que tout à l'heure je
mentionnais l'aspect culturel dans
l'éducation
et peut-être que la boucle sera en tout
cas temporairement bouclée parce que
cette culture elle fait partie
intégrante de l'éducation et du projet
politique
effectivement que je que je mène avec
mon équipe autour de cette éducation
d'un pic n'est en tout cas qu'il faudra
le baril vous aussi des idées au niveau
culture et loisirs vous voulez créer un
événement d'envergure communales ou
encore construire un stade nautique
le stade nautique c'est un des projets
phares de notre programme alliance avec
difficile de faire la première année
est-ce qu'il va falloir quand même
travaillé sur le sujet en profondeur
avec le club et avec les usagers avec
avec les différents acteurs qui compare
la fédération entre aude mais l'objectif
c'est d'avoir à coeur motti qui serait
situé sur le futur quartier des sahwa et
qui soit le remplacement de la cuisse
de l'art de la piscine actuelle qui est
sous dimensionné et qui manque de
créneaux pour les utilisateurs que je
sois grand public où le club avec qui
j'ai pu j'ai pu discuter dans les
différents projets à différentes idées
que l'on a eues on souhaite le labellisé
la ville en conservatoire un
conservatoire de musique du monde
conservatoire il survit encore il faut
pas les faut pas le nier mais la ville
isation d'un conservatoire votre raison
d'être des associations c'est plutôt
d'avoir diversité de lieux de réunion
pour les associations d'avoir vraiment
la maison des associations ça se fait
dans d'autres communes et sa rationalise
la fois les coûts élevés d'une
organisation
on a aussi des projets portent de moins
des jeunes sur les terrains extérieurs
on a parlé des déserts de cette ville de
lorca où est donc ça nous inquiète c'est
dur et ce qui fonctionne bien à l'idée
c'est d'en mettre dans tous les cas
qu'il n'y a pas dans tous les quartiers
et également des démunis des vignes et
terrains de sport comme les bras qui
existe aujourd'hui
la sainte inquisition la commune mais il
faut les fait partie des choses à
améliorer et à mettre dans d'autres
quartiers parce qu'ils sont pas sur tous
les quartiers les tous aux alentours de
8 minutes de temps de parole est ce que
l'un d'entre vous monsieur pape
justement souhaite réagir
oui je voulais répondre à monsieur
martin j'aime ma ville évidemment que
j'aime ma ville mais ça ne m'empêche pas
de penser qu' il ya un côté dortoir à
guyancourt et qu' il faut qu'on se
réveille et en fait quels que soient les
résultats des élections dimanche soir
peu importe que ce soit dans la majorité
dans l'opposition je m'engage à a2a a
travaillé sur les bio dit monsieur
martin est ce que vous souhaitez réagir
il ne nie pas et porte heureusement il
ya encore des choses à améliorer sur la
ville de guyancourt j'en suis bien
conscient et et j'en suis ravi parce
qu'ils sont un vrai projet voilà et je
suis enthousiaste pour aller vers ça y'a
pas de soucis monsieur barry si vous le
souhaitez une vingtaine de secondes
oui va jusqu'à un projet aussi je vais
vous vous citez tout à l'heure c'est
l'accompagnement scolaire à travers le
sport parce que ça c'est quelque chose
qui plaît qui existent aussi dans
d'autres communes où on associe la
réussite scolaire
sport on sort de l'école en fin de
journée on veut aller au club de foot et
dont on passe par une étape
accompagnement accompagnement scolaire
en association avec le avec le club par
exemple alors nous arrivons à la fin de
ce débat ont fait un dernier point sur
les chronos euro doivent parler vous
avez un peu d'avancé aux alentours des 8
minutes 40
grégory pape et françois morton vous
êtes à égalité aux alentours de 8
minutes 15
c'est le moment de la carte blanche
monsieur allait pouvoir a développé
pendant une minute ou deux minutes à peu
près en fonction de candidats une idée
un thème la pole à la parole va être
donné dans le sens inverse de la
première question
donc c'est vous françois morton qui
allait débuter cette carte blanche
vous avez environ deux minutes alors
pour le coup je vais rejoindre
effectivement un certain nombre de
propos de monsieur pape puisque ma carte
blanche est autour de la santé voilà
j'ai eu la grande chance d'être invité à
une manifestation des soignants de
l'hôpital mignot mardi dernier et je me
suis rendu avec grand plaisir pour les
soutenir parce que vous savez que la
situation de l'hôpital
j'ai d'ailleurs un peu seul avec ma
collègue daniel vial adjointe au maire
de lui en cours puisque nous étions les
deux seuls et sharp présente lors de
cette manifestation et c'est bien
dommage
voilà je tiens aussi effectivement à
souligner parce que c'est le service
public et c'est bien ce service public
qui a tenu notamment lors de cette
période fort compliqué alors sur la
ville de guyancourt on a effectivement
une action locale a mené j'en suis
parfaitement conscient alors vous le
savez probablement la ville depuis en
cours et ça n'est pas un hasard obtenu
le label descente et de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
et parce que elle est effectivement
équipé avec un certain nombre de
structures je pense évidemment à la
maison de santé pluridisciplinaire à la
clinique de soins de suite
avec l'expansion aussi de l'ehpad dans
le quartier des saules
mais nous allons être confrontés très
rapidement un phénomène que certains
autres connaissent déjà d'ailleurs qui
est notamment le départ à la retraite
d'un certain nombre de médecins qu'ils
soient généralistes ou spécialistes
alors sachez que nous travaillons sur
cette action parce que l'idée c'est de
pouvoir garder les médecins à guyancourt
d'en faire venir de nouveaux aussi au
travers d'un terrain d'un travail de
partenariat avec l'université mais on
leur
seront également des conditions
d'accueil qui pourrait être favorable
pour et à ce titre nous avons déjà
depuis près d'un an maintenant entamer
un travail notamment de recensement de
lieu dans tous les quartiers qui
pourrait effectivement faire l'objet de
l'accueil de médecins de cabinets
médicaux
l'idée étant de pouvoir mettre aussi ses
médecins en réseau parce que je crois
que c'est important de ne pas avoir un
médecin isolé de moins en moins dagorn
et de pouvoir collectivement accueillir
ses médecins le mieux possible sur la
ville début en eau
merci françois morton c'est à vous
redonne fabarez vous avez environ une
minute trente minutes en bas je vais je
vais fermer et à leur fusion innovants
pour conclure ce débat je rappelle qu'on
a attrait et sur un programme de 84
engagement donc tout serait irréalisable
tous sont finançables sans augmentation
de l'imposition
cap sur quelques sujets forts l'éco
quartier
ce sera le premier écoquartier sur la
ville malgré la présence dans les
mandats précédents de la partie
demanderesse écologistes sur la liste il
y avait des quotas telle installé sur
sur la ville le centre nautique j'en ai
parlé la construction d'un nouveau
centre technique municipal norme hpe
qu'elle viendra mettre conviendra à tous
et une cuisine centrale ce que je veux
juste dire c'est que le vainqueur du
premier tour ce qui était l'abstention
l'objectif c'est que le deuxième tour ya
un peu plus de personnes de kyle qu'ils
aillent voter
je vais juste faire garder à l'esprit
que le score de monsieur horten 42% n'a
été fait cas des 2500 un peu moins de
1600 par dont 20 électeurs sur dix huit
inscrits et qu'aujourd'hui tout est
possible donc j'appelle j'appelle les
électeurs à nous à nous rejoindre
il ya une nouveauté pour nous dimanche
prochain le 28 28 juin il est d'origine
et termine avec vous mais vous avez à
deux minutes de parole ou eddie mercier
je voudrais utiliser ma carte blanche
pour parler du logement de sospel à
guyancourt on n'a pas apporté ce thème
là pour la liste de lyon pour tous
l'objectif assumé 50% pour le la liste
de rodolphe baril est l'objectif est de
25%
ils pourront comme me le reprendre s'il
me tromper mais peu importe
c'est pas parler de vos idées à vous et
ne pourront pas rester je pense qu'il
faut vraiment enfin le social c'est
l'adn de guyancourt il faut pas aller
contre celle historique de guyancourt il
faut il faut le développer évidemment
évidemment qu'il faut il faut faire tout
pour loger les guillon pour toi qui es
les enfants bien pour toi ou les
personnes qui veulent venir travailler à
guyancourt mai mais je trouve que ses
parents de services aux habitants de les
laisser en location voilà le parcours
résidentiel
il faut accentuer ce l'accession à la
propriété
vous savez en fait je m'occupe d'un d'un
forum facebook du rayon court news il ya
3000 monde et récemment il ya quelques
jours j'ai fait un live sur une
résidence sociale et je discute avec une
dame et il me dit mais savez monsieur ça
fait trente ans que je suis locataire
ici 30 ans et elle a calculé
elle aurait pu déjà être propriétaire de
son logement
donc elle aurait pu être tranquille et
voilà on ne lui a pas rendu service fal
et des faucons de l'aide à être
propriétaire à la retraite arrivée à la
retraite elle sera toujours locataires
donc pour moi pour moi faut vraiment
développé à l'accession à la propriété
ce que je voulais juste fini en en
appelant ce 35 ans les duisans courtois
aller voter dimanche prochain
là vous avez vu les élections ont permis
de faire commencer à faire bouger les
choses
donc laissez pas les autres décider pour
vous vous avez le choix entre trois
listes
nous serons vraiment nos priorités c'est
santé sécurité solidarité merci à vous
merci à grégory pape
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat vous êtes tous les trois aux
alentours des 10 minutes c'est un débat
à revoir sur notre site internet où
notre application mobile à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]